He said
that the most beloved prayer
of the entire week to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
is the salah of in the masid in on the
morning of J. This is the most virtuous.
Obviously many of us we have jobs you
know we work we have a particular sleep
schedule a lot of us you know have to be
places at certain times so it might be a
little bit difficult to make it to the
masid for on a daily basis but if you
were to pick any salah of the entire
week to go to
it should be and your first choice
should be on the day of J on the morning
of J. This is the most virtuous and
beloved salah to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala of the entire week and in general
and
generally speaking of all the prayers
and and
the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said,
[Silence]
he said,
"If people only knew
the
amount of reward Lord
that awaits the person who makes salah
in Jama
or is then people would come to these
prayers even if they could only come
crawling on their hands and knees due to
the incredible reward. And this is
something that we often have to ask
ourselves.
We have to test ourselves. Test our
motivations.
Test our our
test our motivations. Test our
you know what it is that drives us to
do things, what our true intentions are
in anything.
for instance, if we knew for a
fact,
if I knew positively
that every time I go to make salah in
the masid, I'm going to get $100. I'm
going to get, let's start with something
large. I'm going to get $100,000
just for going and making salah in the
masid in Jama. Would this masid be big
enough to contain the crowds that would
come to make salah? Forget a
hundred,000. I bet you if it was a $100
incentive, if it was $50, there would be
people that would make it their
full-time job just to go to different
masids at the time of
and that reward exists and it's an
eternal reward. However, you have to
wait for it. You have to wait for it to
receive it. Not very long, just a little
while. But as soon as you leave this
world and transition into the next, upon
your death, you will be rewarded by
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. And there are
rewards for making salah in J
in this.
For instance, the prophet sallall.aii
Wasallam said in
he said
[Silence]
that if a person
makes in the masid 40 consecutive
prayers prayers not missing the first
the initiating of each prayer 40 prayers
in a row consecutively
their hearts will be protected from
hypocrisy
they will be guarded from hypocrisy for
the rest of their lives this is their
reward for putting in such a diligent
effort and coming to make salah so
anyways just a reminder that tomorrow is
J and there are many traditions and
rights that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam taught us in preparation for J
or on the day of J whether we are going
to or not.
And so those begin on the night of Jum
because
in Islam the night comes before the day.
And it could only be that. Not just
in the night but in reality itself night
was first and then light. Right? So the
night comes before the day. And so the
night of J is tonight. What we call
Thursday night which is actually Friday
night in Islam.
The prophet Sam
said in
he said,
"Whoever recites
on the night of J,
it will be as a light for him from
wherever he is in in the world all the
way to
the ancient house of Allah, the Kaa. It
will light his way to the Kaa from
wherever he is. The prophet sallall.aii
wasallam mentioned that the most
virtuous prayer is the prayer of the
morning of J. As we just heard in Jama,
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam then
obligated taking a bath bathing for the
occasion of J upon every
upon every Muslim who is of the age of
puberty.
Whether you are going to Jum or not,
whether you are male or female, these
are one of the rights of Juma.
And so a person is to bathe. And the way
that the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
bathed is the best way to bathe in any
situation in any case as described his
bathing. the way that he would bathe
in the most detail. However, the minimum
of what is considered bathing in Islamic
f is that a person have the intention of
bathing and have the water of bathing go
over their entire body
including their mouth and nose. This
is the bare minimum of bathing. The
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
was described in the narration of
when he would bathe he would bathe in
the following way. He would begin with
washing his hands three times and then
he would wash his private parts front
and back and then he would make woo as
he would for any prayer. So the hands,
the mouth, the nose, the face, the arms,
wiping over the head, the ears, but he
would keep his feet to last. And then he
would pour the water over his head three
times, ensuring that the water reached
to the roots of his hair to the roots of
his hair. Because the prophet
sallallah.aii Wasam
and 99%
of the people the men in his time had
long hair in the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam the Arabs
viewed that long hair was ha it was
considered to be part of the allure and
the respectable traits of a man that
he would have long hair the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's hair was
always long except in Omrah. He made
Omrah how many times? Anyone know? Once
incorrect. Anyone else? I can shoot down
now. Twice. Well, we're getting close.
But no, more than that.
Four times. Was that just a shot in the
dark or you knew it? You didn't know it?
Okay. Well, you know, you got there
anyways. Alhamdulillah. He made Omrah
four times and he made Hajj one time.
During these times, his hair was
narrated to be short and when it would
grow out after the rights of Omrah or
Hajj, it would some companions would
narrate that it would be to his ear.
Some would narrate that it would be to
his shoulders, but that's when it was
growing out. Otherwise, his hair was
always long, always. and he always kept
his hair and braids. Some people
especially the younger brothers you
know they get excited they hear that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam had
long hair so they'll grow out long hair
and then their hair will look a
woman from the back you see them and
it's that's a sister right this is
not how his hair was saiam
his hair was always braided it was
either in three or four braids always
and he always kept his head covered
with a
with a turban or something of the sort.
But anyways, he would pour the water on
his head three times to ensure that the
water reached to the roots of his hair
and then he would wash the right side of
his body and then he would wash the left
side of his body and then he would wash
his feet. In another wording of the
narration, he would then move and then
wash his feet. Why? Because they didn't
have drains. It wasn't a shower. Don't
imagine it that. He would move
because he just bathed right here on the
ground. And so he would take a few steps
over and then wash his feet to ensure
that his feet were clean when he left
the place where he bathed. And so this
is the most comprehensive way that the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam would
bathe for the occasion of Jum.
Another right of the day of Jum for men
only is to wear their best and finest
clothes
to brush their teeth.
This is for men and women. But the
finest clothes and wearing perfume. This
is specific to men who are coming to
Jum. The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
commanded that we brush our teeth for J.
And what a lot of people don't know
is that the way he would brush his teeth
sam
is he would use you know but any brush
will do and he would brush his teeth but
part of that is also he would brush his
tongue.
And also,
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
narrated to have brushed his tongue so
thoroughly and as far back to where he
would gag while he is brushing his
tongue. Sallallam.
This is where bad breath comes from. Bad
breath comes from the tongue. And so,
, because we, you know, grow up in
this kind of western culture where if
you're not brushing your teeth with
Colgates, you're not brushing your
teeth. It has to be this type of
toothpaste and it has to be with this
type of toothbrush. And it right.
The prophet sallallah.aii wasallam and
his companions would constantly brush
their teeth. As a matter of fact, the
least amount they would brush their
teeth is when they would wake up, when
they would enter their homes, and at
each salah they would brush their teeth.
That's the bare minimum. But because of
our current society, we usually, you
know, brush our teeth in the morning,
right? And then we go out all day and
then we have hot sauce and barbecue
sauce and some of us smoke and some of
us whatever. And then by the time bhar
or assur comes a person's breath could
scare a herd of buffalo off a off a
cliff. Rather a brush is something that
you should carry with you always and you
brush your teeth at each woo at each
salah. The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam said, "Had it not been, had I
not feared it being too cumbersome for
my people, I would have commanded my
ummah to brush their teeth at each
prayer." He would have made it
obligatory, but he was afraid it would
be too difficult for them. So it's just
shy of difficult of of obligatory to the
point where he said
continued to insist that I brush my
teeth that I was afraid I was going to
brush my teeth loose and they would
start falling out. This is what the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said.
Another sunnah is to wear some kind of
perfume or cologne for men. not for
women outside of their home. This is for
men. And to come to the salah
the bare minimum of coming to J is
before the im gets on the
because the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
tells us that there are angels at the
doors of every masid
and they have scrolls that they take
down the names of the people who come to
the masjid in the order in which they
arrive
and these scrolls go directly to Allah
upon completion.
And so once the imam ascends the mimba
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
said the angels then roll their scrolls
and come into the masid to listen to the
so after the imam gets onto the meimbo
of course it doesn't mean you should
turn around and go home no if you're if
you're coming you need to come it's
still an obligation but the reward of
jum for it being a forgiveness between
two jum and so on and so forth all those
virtues those virtues virtues end at the
time that the im ascends the meim. This
is when those virtues end. So this is
the bare minimum for a person coming to
another and final right of the day of J
is a salah upon the prophet.
The more a person makes salah upon the
prophetam
during the day of the more virtuous it
is
mentions in his book on salah upon the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he
said some scholars mention the minimum
is a thousand times while others mention
that the minimum amount of times to make
a salah upon the prophet on j is 300
times. So inshallah we will end with
that. Maybe we will continue this
next week. Inshallah may Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala grant us all the reward of the
day of J and the rights of